Ladies and gentlemen, I'm retiring from YouTube. That's right. I'm done.
Susan's taken advantage of me for far too long.
Been paying her way too much money and I'm sick of it, quite frankly.
And I need to make this financial decision for me, for my family. Look,
this $10 million studio it's expensive.
The first mortgage payment came in and quite frankly, I am drowning in debt.
And enough is enough guys. A man can only take so much before he,
as the filings throw in the towel. But before I do it,
I need to expose the biggest con artists in the entire fake guru
industry. I've never talked about them because you know,
I didn't want to burn any bridges.
I knew that I wanted to be nice to these guys. I mean, it's not even just one.
It's actually a group of three. Okay.
Three people that I've never called out because I'm afraid they have big,
big shot lawyers. Um, but it's finally time.
I called them out and those three people are Tom Nashville's or
Grinnellian Mike wouldn't.
I know you guys thought we were all friendly and stuff like that,
but I was really like a little mole inside their operation.
I was only pretending so that I could later expose it,
use them for who they really are. That's right. Bring the screen down, boys,
Spencer Cornelia to start.
Now you may know Spencer as a real estate investor,
someone who's passionate about finance,
but I see a Photoshop artist T he claims in his banner that he was on
wheel of fortune, his name,
but I looked through literally thousands of hours of footage and literally found
no mentions of the name, Spencer Cornelia. Additionally,
when you look at below this,
I know a lot of people would miss this little detail, but it says guru killer,
which rhymes? I don't know if you guys know this with coffee Zilla,
which can only mean one thing. Spitzer. Cornelia may have blood on his hands.
Guys. Wouldn't Caleb Maddix went missing. I always wondered. I mean,
after my livestream, he said he was going to make daily videos. He never did.
And I think at this point, even the police are asking, where is Kaitlin Maddix?
And does the guru killer have anything to do with it?
I don't know if Spencer did it,
but let's just look in those eyes real quick.
And I think we can make a pretty reasonable assumption. Next bridge.
I'm burning Tom Nash. This man is a thumbnail plagiarist.
He has one good thumbnail idea and proceeds to plagiarize it off himself
for months with no attribution. Disgusting.
Now I get it to the common man. You see six distinct thumbnails.
I see six copies next. And this is, this is what actually hurts. Mike,
when it right, many of you, including myself,
are fooled by this guy for a very long time.
Mike has a successful show called entrepreneur, bingo, I,
myself and many others were a fan of this, uh,
where he's hanging out in this gigantic office space.
You see him as successful and you know, popular,
but the truth is far more sinister. See, I was leaked by one of Mike's interns,
this shocking photo.
This is the real state of Contra preneur. Bingo.
It's all been a green screen. We caught them boys.
We caught them who would lie to their audience with something like this.
Let me just ask you this.
What kind of psycho would tell their audience months and months for weeks and
weeks that they're somewhere. They're not, not me.
I've never lied to you guys in my life.
I've never been wrong about anything and literally never known it was green
screen until the shocking footage came out. Um, Mike ex-post now guys,
now that I've burned those bridges, there's no going back on this retirement.
There's no way I could show my face in this circle again.
So let's just go all the way through. Why am I retiring?
Cause it's not just randomly, I'm not doing this for no reason.
It's because I recently learned the truth about retirement,
that people aren't going to tell you. Um, see,
I watched Joshua flukes video on retirement. You may know him.
He's been on the podcast before Josh has a very main stream.
View of retirement. Let's hear what it is.
This is what retirement actually looks like. This is what retirement looks like.
Ladies and gentlemen, this is what I used to believe about retirement.
That retirement means you're old, but that was back when I was a big, dumb,
dumb, like Josh flu. And I didn't mean to expose them there, but Josh, sorry,
you're in the cross ears right now. Everybody's getting it on retirement day.
See Joshua fluke is totally wrong about retirement as are most people.
Most people think of retirement as you save up money so that you can retire.
I learned recently that you have to retire to make enough money to retire,
which is why I'm retiring guys.
Welcome to my retirement video and why you should retire. And yes,
we're four minutes and 30 seconds in,
and I'm just getting to the point of this video. But hold on guys,
it's my retirement video. I can do it how I want.
So this may be the most important little slide deck you've ever seen to
retirement. One-on-one buy copies of it. Cause if you're in the old model,
you probably think that retirement is for old people. And that's the mistake.
This lie, this false narrative is being mostly propagated by one man,
Joshua fluke, the YouTuber. Um,
the truth is retirement's made to make you more money.
And I know that's confusing to a lot of you. So let me explain.
See the truth is I used to be negative towards retirement too.
I mean like back in the day, a long time ago, I was Downing people who did this.
I was hating on them. I was making fun of them and their taglines,
but that's before I knew the truth guys, that's before I got enlightened,
I used to propagate the, this poor mindset, this poor mentality, you know,
and that's how you stay poor is by not retiring early, but luckily guys,
I'm a non-stop learner. So eventually I figured it out.
And it's also a great way to get job security guys,
because this is the old saying goes, once you retire, you can never be fired.
Now I want you guys to know also get arm yourself with evidence, as they say,
because all the greats have done it. Listen, Connor McGregor show.
You know who he is. He retired. He said, I have decided to retire young.
Thanks for the cheese catches later.
Now what happened years after he retired,
after retiring from fighting,
he made the most money he had ever made in his career fighting. Look,
this is the face of a man making a lot of money. I know it may not look like it,
but wow, this is the face of a winner.
Now I know you're savvy and you want more evidence, fine evidence. Number two,
we have Linus tech tips, ladies and gentlemen.
This is a small little YouTuber who would thought of retiring 10 months ago.
He announced it. He got millions of views. The video went viral, uh,
because all of a sudden, everyone freaked out, Oh, he's retiring. He's retiring.
Now. Look at him. He's the number one tech YouTuber.
But maybe you're not into these YouTubers, right?
You want to know about traditional media.
Maybe you don't trust this new showbiz, right? You take a look at old showbiz.
Jay Leno was about to be fired. So he retired.
He said he was handing over the show to Conan. O'Brien good luck next week,
my friend. And then he took it back. Yeah,
I'll take the show back. Once you retire, you can never be fired guys.
There are even people you may not have even known are retired and are successful
because of it. This is Pewdie pie. I've already retired. He said,
don't believe me, roll the clip. I'm already retired. Now. Look at him. Look,
he's one of the biggest YouTubers. Now this is how you get successful. Guys.
Other big YouTubers. You may know morgues,
obviously one of the greats on YouTube, he retired.
I'm sorry to do this. I'm quit YouTube.
Now look at him guys. This is just a pattern of behavior. I mean,
I don't mean to shake you guys up with these things, but as uncle Ben says,
facts, don't care about your feelings. Now that just about covers it.
But I just wanted to conclude for you guys a little bit here. Um, I am retiring,
listen, that's fact number one, I had to do it for the sake of my career.
I decided I was finally ready to get serious about working. So I had to quit.
Uh, I also wanted to say, please smash like, and subscribe guys,
because big things are coming and my retirement because I may be quitting,
but it's just the beginning.